[Music]
hi my name's dr. bird I've been in
practice for 27 years I've worked on
over 40,000 people a trained 2,500
doctors thank you for your family the
authenticity is transparent like what
comes through your genuine you can tell
that you're in this to really help
people and you're just motivating a lot
of people to do the same and it's a
synergy that keeps growing the keto diet
is the way to go
intermittent fasting is also the way to
go you want to be healthy first and then
you lose weight as dr. Burke said
insulin prevents you from tapping into
your fat every time you meet you spike
insulin 130 pounds with keto and
intermittent fasting people want to look
like asana because I really learned a
lot this alone and tells us that our
body is very well designed for fasting
the key is getting that recovery when
you workout
it's literally like well there's no
breakfast dinner I'm sick and tired of
being sick and tired and I thank you for
opening my eyes to lost 370 pounds on
Kido in two years I lost 346 keep doing
what you're doing and I love it really
seems to really want to help people so I
want to say thank you to him and Karen
and of course he couldn't do that
without his beautiful supportive wife
dr. Berg absolutely rocked because his
knowledge is so digestible you can
assimilate it and understand it and
bring him together all the information
that we need to hear no we're not
hearing otherwise thank you so much for
changing my life thank you for
everything you're doing I believe you
have a ministry that you're doing this
blessing others and in turn that's
allowing me to bless others as well Kito
and dr. Bergen is the best person to
tell you how to do that
thank him for his hard work every full
day of putting out an amazing hunt and
thank you for all that you do and
I'd love to see her cook more cuz a lot
of people want to season more recipes my
goal is to help people find the simple
truths of health some baking tray to
help your body thanks for watching